[Música]
cuando llegue a colombia
hace tres años no sabía hablar español
cuando llegue a colombia hace tres años
no tenía mucho contacto
y mucho dinero en estudiar
y siempre me quedé con
una cosa
una cosa tenía no tenía muchas cosas
pero sí tenía una cosa habitada
les digo que
diez años antes de eso
andaba feliz en mi bicicleta yendo al
colegio
y ahí
pasó algo que me cambió la vida
entonces estoy saliendo
de mi casa
en bicicleta feliz
y ahí me para mi mamá me cerró las rolas
ponte ese chaleco
qué vergüenza como de llegar al colegio
con eso
eso fue un trauma para mí porque me
obligaba porque obviamente es mi mamá y
me quiere cuidar
entonces
yo ahí entendí algo muy importante
tuve ganas de cambiar las cosas generar
un pequeño campo
10 eso pasó a los 3 años
diez años después llegó a colombia para
terminar mis estudios y me dio cuenta
que bogotá
que en bogotá está pasando algo
espectacular con la bicicleta y me doy
cuenta que puedo generar un pequeño
cambio
y ahí es donde empiezo a emprender y a
pensar de eso
no va a seguir tomar acción de más
personas
entonces una pequeña paréntesis
yo llegué sin saber nada de lo que era
una máquina de coser obviamente
yo soy politólogo
y terminó haciendo una chaqueta una
chimba para montar en bici
entonces cómo pasa eso y es lo que
quiero compartir con ustedes gracias en
mi historia
pasar de una idea a un prototipo es muy
complicado
pero lo más importante es de arrancar
y nosotros en este momento arrancamos
con algo tremendamente feo
el primer prototipo que hicimos lo tengo
acá se lo voy a hablar es horrible
feliz es de algodón porque obviamente yo
no sabía de materiales de textiles nadie
es de algo se lo voy a mostrar
eso es el primer prototipo que nos
permitió generar 130.000 dólares de
venta en menos de 2 meses
y no es una broma es verdad ese es un
trapo horrible pero por esas lecciones
no es que es un trapo horrible
sí no
que hemos arrancado así sea con algo
super feo y yo creo que el mensaje no de
los mensajes que quiero transmitir es
que lo más importante para emprender es
arrancar
así sea con una vaina corrí blé un trapo
porque hoy en día este trapo tiene otro
valor simbólico
entonces pasamos de este trapo horrible
hicimos una integración es decir una
repetición de prototipos tras prototipos
tras prototipos de prueba y error
porque cuando uno no sabe la mejor forma
de equivocarse y ya hacer algo un poco
mejor
me demoré con año y medio haciendo es
solamente es probando x
ahí es donde juega algo muy importante
el hecho de hacer cosas localmente en
colombia es algo que a mí me cambió la
vida
y cambió la vida a muchísimas sociales
personas porque porque es importante
cuidar el potencial de industria el
potencial industrial que tiene colombia
es que a nosotros pequeños emprendedores
nos permite ir a ver un pequeño taller
pero yo tengo una idea yo creo que
realmente es especial
realmente es una idea valiosa que podría
ayudar a otros 30 hagámoslo entonces yo
me fui de taller en taller pues siendo
como este trapo horrible
y mejorando mejorando y mejorando
gracias al tejido
industrial local colombiano hice mi
sueño real cosa que nunca hubiera podido
pasar en
y otras partes del mundo
pero entonces una vez uno tiene
una idea consolidada un prototipo ya que
uno puede tocar
ya la chaqueta estaba cogiendo forma
como hago para para producir esa vida
pasar de una idea un prototipo y un
prototipo a un producto esto es el reto
que tenían yo tengo mucha suerte porque
no va nació al mismo momento que el
crowdfunding que kickstart texas que el
financiamiento participativo lo que
permite estas plataformas es que haya
una persona que publique un video que lo
muestra a muchas personas y esas
personas tienen la posibilidad de decir
sabes que roland
tu chaqueta realmente me parece una
chimba para montar mis
a partir de este momento empezamos a
generar confianza la confianza es algo
clave
hay 1400 personas
me apoyaron que apoyaron al equipo que
estamos creando diciendo
eso es una buena idea y como lo hicieron
dándome algo de plata y gracias a esto
yo puedo armar mi primera producción es
decir pasar del prototipo final al
producto
ha sido un proceso muy complicado y les
voy a contar dos historias sobre este
proceso de la campaña en dos meses hemos
recabado 130.000 dólares es enorme más
plata que nunca hubiera podido imaginar
ver mi cuenta un día
en serio
en 5 horas hemos recabado de 5000
dólares que era la meta que nosotros
necesitábamos para hacer 50 chaquetas 5
por 50 chaquetas wow
en este momento hicimos 1400
y a la mitad de la campaña
hubo un gran problema problema de
confianza
no teníamos donde hacer esas chaquetas
tenemos 60 mil dólares de pedidos ni las
mil personas esperan dos chaquetas y
boom la persona que nos lleva hasta los
cheques sí no
problema gigantesco a un estrés grande
vuelve y juega a hacer las cosas
localmente en bogotá nos salvó
porque porque nosotros trabajamos con
textiles de lafayette los pudimos
recibir y los podemos poner muy
fácilmente en donde nuestro nuevo
proveedor
en menos de un mes pudimos adaptarnos a
un cambio gigantesco gracias al hecho
que nosotros hacemos las cosas
localmente lo que quiero decir es que
hacer las cosas localmente acá en bogotá
no solamente es algo chévere para el
medio ambiente sino que es una fortaleza
para una empresa
superamos este reto nuevamente y ahí
cuando teníamos finalmente esa cantidad
de dinero en una cuenta nos tocó traerla
a colombia
entonces vamos a ver
la empresa estaba conformado hace 15
días
y vamos a hablar a los temas de la
cuenta a nosotros nos encantaría traer
130.000 dólares de eeuu para poder hacer
chaquetas a chimba para monte misa
ok
y nos vamos un mes y medio en convencer
a esas personas que es así o sea no
somos lo que ustedes puedan llegar a
pensar yo sé que es un poco confuso pero
pero si realmente hacemos que las máxima
banda de mí
convencimos al gerente del banco que no
éramos
narcotraficante es básicamente
básicamente para decir cómo es
y empezamos a trabajar y superamos un
nuevo reto otro mensaje que quiero dejar
el reto de los emprendedores es de
pasársela resolviendo pequeños problemas
como ellos o grandes problemas pero eso
es el día a día entonces no los tienen
antes no es normal tener muchos
problemas cuando uno emprende es normal
entonces
todo eso lo que estoy contando y son
muchas personas felices y unas de las
cosas más importantes que yo con las
cuales me quedo esa campaña de dos meses
es la comunidad y la familia que hemos
creado alrededor de una misma pasión que
es el psiquismo urbano entonces yo
quiero mostrarles quiénes son esas
personas tenemos una persona en berlin
para mí es fantástico es increíble estar
en colombia en berlín
enfrente la parte brown tenemos una
persona en londres en francia
en roma' tenemos una persona en bogotá
si esto es lo que es eso cuando lo
conocen cierto
en suiza en nueva zelandia
en los alpes esos esos son las personas
que dan vida al proyecto es gracias a
esas personas que nosotros pudimos hacer
nuestro sueño realidad
la cosa más importante de todas
al momento de emprender
y yo creo que es un buen ejemplo eso
porque yo cuando llegué a colombia no
sabía hablar español
cuando llegue a colombia no sabía coser
no tenía mucho dinero ni muchos
contactos
pero si tenía buena cosa
lo que tenía
es una actitud para generar un cambio
exponencial en este mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]